lovely looking CJ open works between
Matthews and Barnes into the lane three
tenths of a second remaining for the
Dallas Mavericks they got a heave it
Harris well down the floor it comes and
he overshoots the rim Blazers wind up
and Dallas did what I thought they would
do they sent two defenders that and
Wesley Matthews plays the high side
Harrison Barnes goes to try to meet them
but when you got a handle and you're
crafty as CJ McCollum sometimes it
doesn't matter two big buckets for CJ
McCollum
ugly Payton cross-court Oladipo cannot
find it opening now fires
[Applause]
sends it to overtime number two about
this little fake and Elsa Paton along
the baseline could close down that first
by Robertson Wow nice job by the victors
just creating a little spin step to
speed his vows good Dante Exum who's
done a nice job off the bench play
making and playing defenses in deep
three by CJ McCollum at three versa
bonuses back of the funders Oladipo been
a streak and packet
where you come from amazement you wanna
see somebody on a pogo stick watch this
no you don't we used to do dunks like
that he's in the building right now he's
one of the color analyst for the land
Hawks late in the clock at CJ McCollum
throwing it out to a zebu for three
needed that one good fight and now with
five seconds here's one the depo three
seconds we saw a way to raise up a huge
overtime three but they send miles away
cuz they don't want to TT which is good
because Nate McMillan did that and right
here victus backs him up shoots a little
long dan dan on and his goes down now
there may be more than three tenths of a
second but at that point who cares
Nick knock down the three Quinn Victor
Oladipo since he has worn the blue and
gold of the Pacers young ladies huh
it'll be the ruffles are down there's
McCollum goes down the middle and dunks
steal by faking the balls lose
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
your great-great fine Pakistan
it's his pocket on the push looking at
idle ballgame
[Applause]
slap it down usually rest call that on
the slap down this time CJ gets away
with that and the double time to sugar
the pocket at stupid three seconds to go
to Americans convert the third incident
point to left took the three twice CJ
Holmes Bunder completely around and hit
the three that's worse than a poster a
spin around one more look at the
McCallum as Dirk thought he was that's
like one of those own
[Applause]
down that right hand Jimmy Butler over
plays that side give it back to the left
finish in traffic good this business
surrounded know who and that's a big
play against one of the top defensive
players in the NBA Jimmy Butler's gonna
get a lot of votes for Defensive Player
of the Year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it just depends on how much offensively
the other table we had it McCallum find
his way through that crowd and then
banked it in he had just hands up and
you can see moving look at that CJ is
amazing but he keeps control of his body
that beautiful handles there to to weave
through traffic and then get it up off
the glass
sweatpants adoptive Oladipo slings it
over them the shoulder and it banked it
in snap by Victor Oladipo it's going to
the rim earlier and so this one why not
the success breeds success dance
teachers visitors down to nine seconds
McCollum takes it off the dribble for
the tie yes and that's a point for left
the fourth quarter in the NBA 18 for
McCollum they just simply wouldn't be
let Gilad get open in Portland's very
comfortable with the call of doing mrs.
temple fell down
makalah we open look at the hoop watch
temple here
back he just kind of stumbled
feeding it also took dust away
really open digs up from a call when CJ
is money from that spot and now you
don't need anybody there's only five
seconds you need this
to stop dribble penetration bonus last
three all the tipo
[Applause]
depo beats the buzzer he is 21 on the
night no doubt it
out of his hands in
in a big buckets time outs of he wants
him midcourt dribbles gets to the lane
gets bucks cards that he's fouled 7.6
left and a chance at a three-point play
through when CJ does fought through the
double took up up at the rim
[Applause]
well they had him spread out enough they
had CJ corner these are the strain hun
trying to need as much fruit fall tried
three jumpers in qawwali of warm weather
to plan all night long Westbrook has
been on target with his passes Oh a
Depot with a sweet finish for the
Thunder clear out as you found
CJ djursland score the place foul
we never dribbled again though he did it
up off the glass and Leroy Richardson
says count it what he does takes a lot
of pressure off Lilly Lilly just getting
the rest right now and look at that
that is a guy that can get his own shot
from mid-range he can get to the rim you
have the good fortune to go to visit
with NBA Cares
[Applause]
[Music]
the name is screen pumps a
three-cylinder they've switched it 15
seconds to play seven here's a three by
Oladipo holders out this shot clocks at
five and going down and he knocks it
right down able to get it over the tops
trailing by three Plumbly to bring it in
bounce from the inline they cast it
outside CJ it catches shot isn't bad
catch and shoot three Brennan tie
ballgame and 106 the best for last
watch al-farouq Aminu go down and set
the screen for McCollum it was a little
unorthodox the way it was set up and I
think that's why Morris was a little
late getting out to the shot or break
last year now in his first year here in
Memphis Oladipo beats drops into the
half pork puts it up
yeah bass has had a lot of good offense
going in that first half to all the
Depot goes coast-to-coast and buries the
shot professor and the Pacers have a
double figure halftime lead in Memphis a
20 point I'm living the dream
he's got six threes here's McCullum two
seconds left but Collins gets rid of
Matthews lets it fly at the horn
[Applause]
first West Matthews one of the
outstanding defender said but column
gets it to go they have a little
conversation at the end column says
that's good under good pressure to ended
his career all pac-12 worse yet here's
all the dsm-v on a great cup they have
their largest lead
they never led in the first half all the
Depot has 28 and the Pacers lead it
five middle to paint lasers led by as
many as 13 in the don't see that very
often but when you do you got to replay
that one at some point CJ with the
hammer control whistle just so we can
look at this again see take one scribble
is Smith watch out
go that's that's a very unusual thing to
do Chris
they have great confidence in his Smith
block by Oladipo
that's he's not even in the play in
common
paces push it up that's a hit look at
the fits of blood
Turkish came here no way cheese and deal
with tension and they went 14 and 6 look
at the handles and look at the left hand
dish beautiful hands but these guys are
good to fit so if you gotta know that's
why you gotta move the ball inside what
a shot by Vic
that sums up for sure but I didn't think
he it
gets it up off the glass basically
actually 3d
over the head right-handed off the glass
that was on white side that's his fourth
[Music]
it's the third team foul against the
heat belly there in front of the bench
CJ comes off the screen of Turner turns
the corner rams into Brooks recovers and
stars at the end of the second quarter
CJ macum will have the last word in the
corner we just talked about what a
luxury it is having him at the end of a
clock but eventually it gets to his
hands and he gets it the triple double
in his first career start holding depo
to steal racing against Kidd slipped it
on him with a left hand
punched it left-handed only you see
right here take that Lakers here by
three
[Music]
whoa create the contact but you can see
this again offers up between the legs
and Lonzo ball is too late to turn to
help because mold is closing him up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Victor Oladipo about that was me will
everybody knows you're the guy on the
team that should take the shot
Victor's able of clear space and knock
it down you can see the zero is Phoenix
him to defend as well Corey Joseph
please CJ says never given number was
called yet back bang is not the four
shots and she said Victor's off to a
great start he could shoot any time he
wants almost oh what a shot by Oladipo
he has 21 victor does a nice job faking
getting to the rim p320 take a look at
the Pacific office automation stats and
that move from CJ McCollum it would you
describe what this is though this is the
one where if you're a defender after
that happens you gotta act like the
floor was wet or something there has to
be an excuse on James
stolen by Oladipo Stephenson back to
Oladipo
[Applause]
[Music]
dribble handoff to CJ goes right up the
gut to the rally we get it down the pike
for the two-hand Jam that's how you
started overtime and CJ just kick things
off clock at four Oladipo harassed by
James
Oladipo pulls back high arcing crazy Oh
he knocks it down as the shot clock
expires and a big smile from Oh Latifah
whopper in Blazers trying to best to put
him away
CJ found in the hand he's got a shoe
with because he loses the ankle once
he's pushed he's heading behind the
backboard he can it's left hand and
nothing on that one
[Applause]
they did not use a timeout and it was
Oladipo over Al Horford slowly goes
right Jill cats layup blocked by Wilkins
and the rebound to the head of the block
and CJ McCollum you want to win
show me great recovery and chase-down
block what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content